Eric Palacios from Eric Palacios and  Associates the sponsors of this segment  shares what are the penalties for  domestic battery in today's legal minute  hi I'm Eric Palacios welcome to the  legal minute today's question is what  are the penalties for domestic battery  charge in Nevada first of all Nevada law  defines domestic battery as  intentionally inflicting unlawful  physical force on a current or former  spouse dating partner or certain family  members a first offense is usually a  misdemeanor punishable by fines of 200  to a thousand dollars you have to do 48  to 120 hours of community service and  sometimes you'll spend two days up to  six months in jail you also have six  months to do weekly counseling if you're  accused of domestic violence it's  important that you call an experienced  attorney right away I'm Eric Palacios  this has been the legal minute give Eric  Palacios and Associates a call at  702-44-777 or go to their website at  Eric palacioslaw.com